à monsieur move alors si vous voir est
sur les nerfs oui parce qu'on l'a
prévenu que la maquilleuse et c'est une
langue de [ __ ]
alors il a préparé son affaire et s'est
dit oui même dire que je suis petit
coach travaux casino de leur parler
d'eux mais ferrari que je collectionne
les femmes et toulon ça on lui a dit
mille fois j'ai beaucoup plus méchant
y parait il pas vrai que quand il fait
passer des auditions à des petits jeunes
et surtout à des petites jeunes ils les
martyrs inc comme c'est pas possible un
vrai tyran un ciel bien auditionné ne
sera pas concernée étant de leçons avant
d'ouvrir la terreur 1
on ne l'a jamais dit ça c'est là où je
suis un temps on ne changerait pas trop
traîner ici là m'auditionner dans deux
minutes